[Music]
the offeree sister Jackie and Claudia
have millions of followers on their
social media they're known for throwing
up their hilarious opinions daily on the
morning toast the Millennial morning
show ladies Jackie and Claudia are now
with us
welcome ladies so when you heard them
you write this sound of my own voice
makes me want to die yeah and then you
were wavy but not wavy you know it's
total love because what you do is so
genius why do you think though your show
has hit so hard and resonated we
attributed a lot of the success to the
fact that we're sisters and look we have
this weird like family our whole like
show is just our inside family jokes and
like we're letting people in on like our
sister yeah and there's nothing that we
won't say to each other like we don't
have to tiptoe around each other and I
think people really relate to that
dynamic cuz it reminds them of their own
family right have you ever been offended
by the other on air of course we fight
about Taylor Swift we agree on pretty
much everything we've had the same life
experience so we pretty much agree on
all hot topics except when it comes to
Taylor Swift like I'm true diehard I
have a Taylor Swift fan Instagram
account and tumblr it's called swifty
with no job please follow me and I will
apologize for anything and everything
she doesn't say and Jackie's a critical
fan I'm like I love her music but the
hyping up of everything isn't I can't
even hear it like I'm just a Taylor
Swift apologist and I make I make no
apologies okay wait so the new video me
love it here don't deliver was it worth
all the hype Jackie nothing can ever be
worth that much hype the level of hype
was insane and unless she was putting
out like a 15 song album yeah
technically it's half a song on her part
it's a great song it's a bob the video
was so fun but like why does she have to
like you know dangle this carrot stick
for weeks in advance I did a song I see
how long I just did the hype Clarence
Warrenton a beautiful song beautiful
video beautiful collaboration here for
it all okay do you care about the cat
the secret catfish going off and all
that it's beautiful
dogs mom so I understand the love she
has and it's a special bond you know I
I'm very happy what did you think about
the the feature love love we're not
going to panic at the disco respect the
hell out of panic at the disco and we're
glad to see that Taylor Swift does too
yeah it was just making good decisions
yeah let's talk about this how did we
feel how do millennials feel about
Starbucks if you're gonna go per calorie
per the taste do we care about this
where are we you know what it's like
Starbucks is always trying too hard it's
like you're ready in every mall in
America stop trying so hard and just
make coffee this is a pink dragon drink
this is what I'm wearing today it's good
for a photo I tried to other the unicorn
one and like I literally throw up in my
mouth okay on the count of three let's
do it one two um that's delicious and I
just gained ten pounds it's cotton candy
but you know what I've gotten candy
that's so good I take back everything I
said I'm so glad you guys talked me into
drinking it cuz I just had like the best
drink of my life well you need it
because we're just back from stagecoach
the three of us got was Coachella which
we'll get to you did Coachella too we
like to do both just so we can pin one
against the other what did you think of
stagecoach eh coach is the best weekend
ever ever you're coming back so this is
Country Music Festival shoot like three
nights of music yeah real talent like no
one's singing when there's none of that
hoopla it's just a man and his guitar or
a woman yeah it's just the honky Tonk
there yes what are the trends that we
like and what are the ones that go
bye-bye I saw a lot of like crochet and
fringe and bye I saw it a lot I wore it
a lot yeah and if I wore it I think it's
a cool trend so it's cool I saw a more
like a lot of chains biker vibes Harley
Davidson here for it yeah what I saw too
much of is butt cheek yeah too much
about you know any lower butt cheek the
whole thing you know we saw Ella too as
just booty booty booty a lot of booty
you know it's a kids festival your
teenage daughters were there they were
just like butts everywhere do you nails
I wasn't prepared for the biker thing
there's these women older than me with
handcuffs I'm into it I'm into yeah okay
what about Coachella see Scott no we did
we see you know he saw somebody it was
you were saying do meet each other I
mean I'm sorry gonna say the same like
it's possible but like you know it was a
long weekend it was a long week and the
drinks were flowing you know you know
Coachella is much more of like a work
environment everyone there is like with
brands and just like getting the photo
no one's there to actually enjoy so it's
nice to go to stagecoach and just have a
good time I'll tell you though I enjoyed
wait before we go Kim Kardashian having
a baby shower a CBD baby shower what do
we think well I'm like newly obsessed
with CBD and like I sleep like a log
every night now so good for her good for
I understand it she's the busiest woman
on the planet like if anyone needs CBD
it's gonna be her what is CBD how do I
not know this
it's the marijuana plan when there's two
things in it THC which is the
psychoactive drug and then CBD which is
more like the meditative medicinal
quality right so you can take just that
it's legal and it's more so help you
sleep helps you relax help with anxiety
and from a big fat it has a lot of the
positive effects of matter because it's
work I'm gonna get some CBGB is live
weekdays at 10:30 a.m. Eastern Standard
Time on YouTube ladies if you love that
video
you're gonna love everything on the
access YouTube channel so hit the
subscribe button you can thank me later
hit
now
Thanks